le Conseil Général de la Réunion vous
présente lien social le Conseil général
aux côtés des Réunionnais à la Réunion
on dénombre 3600 personnes atteintes de
la maladie d'Alzheimer au niveau
national c'est plus de 225 000 nouveaux
cas par an l'accroissement du nombre de
personnes
âgées atteintes de cette maladie a
incité les autorités à la déclarer
grande cause nationale en 2007 la
maladie d'Alzheimer c'est quoi quels
sont les effets négatifs sur l'entourage
familial il y a-t-il des prises en
charge on en parle tout de suite dans
lien social
le 17 septembre dernier se déroulait la
Journée mondiale de la maladie
d'Alzheimer à la Réunion afin d'informer
d'échanger d'orienter toutes les
personnes concernées et ainsi faire un
point sur les avancées et aide
disponibles grand public professionnel
de la santé et du secteur médico-social
et famille était présent la maladie
d'Alzheimer est une affection du cerveau
dite neurodégénérative caractérisée par
une perte progressive de la mémoire des
fonctions cognitives et accompagnées de
troubles du comportement elle entraîne
progressivement la disparition des
neurones il n'existe pas à l'heure
actuelle de traitement curatif c'est
pourquoi la prévention et la diffusion
de l'information sur les premiers
symptômes sont aussi primordial afin
d'initier une prise en charge précoce
qui peut ralentir les effets de la
maladie à Saint-André Aline maillot
s'occupe de sa mère atteinte de la
maladie d'Alzheimer ainsi que de son
père invalide
81 ans et ma mère se sont présents au
mois de novembre donc il s'avère que on
a découvert qu'elle a l'Alzheimer depuis
janvier 2013 et c'est suite à une fille
qu'elle a fait en décembre 2012 donc moi
je voyais ou ainsi que ma famille voyait
qu'il y avait quelque chose qui n'allait
pas et sur ce j'ai fait des examens
IRM tout ça et là on a vu qu'elle a un
atrophie au niveau de sa tête on va dire
ça va aller très entourée
il y a le conseil général qui nous aide
au niveau allez on accueille du jour à
Steria le mardi et le jeudi et je suis
en APA pour elle aussi bien qu'au papa
je suis aussi dans français Alzheimer
donc j'y vais une fois par mois et il y
a un psychologue qui est là dans le
groupe donc il nous explique très très
bien
dégénérescence du cerveau donc il y a
plus de il y a les neurones qui se
connectent plus ensemble donc les
informations n'arrivent plus ou c'est
pour ça que des fois elle répète elle
oublie ce qu'elle a déjà fait et il y a
des répétitions quoi et au début pendant
même actuellement c'est c'est encore
difficile pour moi parce que moi en tant
pis voir ma mère comme ça c'est pas
évident c'est un enfant et
on s'énerve bien qu'on sait que c'est la
maladie je suis là vers 8h30 jusqu'à 6h
quand l'option sort de son travail quand
elle arrive si elle a pas
l'embouteillage donc je suis là on va
dire tous les jours tous les jours mes
enfants sont récupérés par leur papa
donc il fait l'heure de voir à manger
les amis sont très importants les
voisins ils savent comment et sa maladie
donc ils mettent très bien quoi très
bien je suis obligée entre guillemets
d'être là tout le temps parce qu'on peut
pas la laisser toute seule parce qu'elle
peut partir
elle peut partir et elle écoute pas papa
voilà et elle avait l'habitude de monter
descendre et c'était une interactive que
j'ai le répit aussi au niveau du conseil
général moi je prends de mercredi
après-midi dans le mois il y a quelqu'un
qui vient me remplacer pendant cet
après-midi là et elles s'en occupe elle
s'en occupe de ma mère quoi pour moi ça
me permet d'être avec mes enfants et
c'est vrai que en demi-journaux on fait
pas beaucoup grand chose mais c'est bien
Alzheimer c'est pas évident parce qu'il
y a plusieurs cas d'Alzheimer il y a
ceux qui sont tranquilles sages il y a
ceux qui sont qui ont l'habitude de
bouger qui vont pas accepter la maladie
et
il y a ceux qui je crois qu'ils vont se
laisser dépérir
sans elle autour d'eux sans famille sans
personne mais il faut s'en occuper
l'intervention du conseil général à
trois orientations fortes soutenir le
maintien à domicile et favoriser
l'intégration des personnes âgées dans
la société
développer l'offre d'hébergement en
famille d'accueil et en établissement et
améliorer la qualité des prises en
charge en maison spécialisée et à
domicile une évaluation a permis et
conclut une meilleure coordination entre
la prise en charge sanitaire et
médico-sociale la Réunion est le premier
département de France en nombre de
places agréées pourvoyeuse d'emplois
cette alternative d'hébergement entre le
maintien à domicile et l'hébergement en
établissement concerne 489 accueillants
familiaux à la Réunion
améliorer l'autonomie et le cadre de vie
des malades reste une priorité pour le
département
le Conseil général se veut actif en
matière de réflexion sur les
améliorations dans tous les domaines
pour pallier cette maladie c'est
pourquoi il finance les actions des
associations intervenant dans le cadre
de la maladie d'Alzheimer et des
maladies apparentées ainsi que nombre de
dispositifs en faveur des personnes
malades ou de leurs aides les services
du conseil général et de la maison
d'aide à la personne se tiennent à la
disposition des familles et des malades
pour leur apporter tous les
renseignements pratiques le Conseil
Général de la Réunion vous a présenté
lien social le Conseil général aux côtés
des Réunionnais